hello I'm Lisa pepper baits the Teaching
Fellow from the School of Management in
the faith and globalization course and I
have the honor to be here today with
Professor HL senator latina from the
University of Virginia Department of
Anthropology welcome professor thank you
for being with us today for having me as
we've discussed this week in faith and
globalization we have been talking about
conflicts in which religion plays a role
and we are very pleased to have you here
today as a resource to help us
understand the role that Buddhism has to
play in the conflict in Sri Lanka I'd
like to ask you a very general question
to start with and that is an overview if
you would provide one of the way that
Buddhism has played a role in the
conflict in your country I think the
most important thing to remember when we
contemplate this question is that
Buddhism is not one thing and we really
have no way of knowing exactly what the
Buddha said historically or
linguistically but we can logically I
think come to some sort of reasonable
conclusion and the Buddhist message very
simply that there is a problem there is
a reason for it and there's a way out
and me outline the way out and there's
no motor Buddhism than that and it has
been of course institutionalized in very
different ways in different countries
and to make this short in sri lanka
itself which is a small country buddhism
is not one thing the kind of buddhism
that we might imagine was the buddha's
own Buddhism is practiced only by a very
very few individuals if any at all most
of the time Buddhism is a popular
religion it has integrated itself into
the pre-existing beliefs of the country
and borrowed also religious
ideas and religious beings to worship
from Hinduism and this is one aspect
which might be my good called the
strictly sort of religious aspect of
Buddhism but then it has a political
aspect there has been going back to at
least 1500 years ago
there is a national chronicle in sri
lanka called the maha van sameen which
means a great genealogy which is a
religious history of the country of the
kings and in the maha ones there is this
myth of the colonization of the country
and is a very clear notion of of an
ideal society there and that ideal
society the island of Sri Lanka belongs
to the exclusively to the similar people
and Eden it is the the well-being of the
country depends on the moral behavior of
the people and in the sense of a
morality derived from Buddhism so long
as people behave morally everything is
fine and therefore it is the
responsibility of the government of the
King to make sure that Buddhism is
protected and nourished and so this is
not this is not this completely it's a
commitment it's enviable no king can
really abandoned this so that is how you
get this other kind of way sir it's a
third kind of Buddhism is a political
Buddhism it is that Buddhism that is the
causing the problems not not with this
own doctrine I see and can you comment
then on the Western understanding of
Buddhism which we I think understand
very simplistically perhaps that peace
is perhaps the most central value in
Buddhism now how do we put that concept
if that is in fact correct
together with the political
that we see at work in Sri Lanka well I
think one way to look at this is every
religion has the message of peace I
don't think this any religion that
advocates violence and Buddhism in
particular has been associated with
peace and people think this is the the
religion the great religion of universal
compassion and this is of course partly
derived from Buddhism but partly also I
think part of the clever propaganda on
the part of Buddhist so for example the
Dalai Lama be associated with peace and
in particularly in this country I think
it the again Buddhism is very varied but
one of the dominant strands of Buddhism
in this country is precisely the Mayan
Buddhism which is one aspect which is
characterized by by the Dalai Lama and
his teachings and the when you get to
the question of how Buddhism and peace
can be you know Buddhism can be employed
in the service of peace that's a very
difficult question because it also has a
very important general dimension you
cannot you can have all kinds of nice
ideas but the question is how do we
translate this into action as I said
before every religion has good idea is
no religion the Red Brigades killing but
it is it is a question of how a religion
and its moral ideas are going to be
translated into practice I think it was
a great insight of Max Weber in his very
famous book called the Protestant ethic
and the spirit of capitalism that he was
able to demonstrate a series of
relations between a set of religious
ideas and capitalism and there is a
general sort of simplistic understanding
of this book as weber having said
religion causes capitalism he didn't say
that
the
he posited the series of the relations
that are interconnected and sort of
causally connected and they are thereby
demonstrated how a religious idea could
become a very secular idea and so I
think it if we are to use religion in
thinking about peace we will have to
think of some kind of mechanism like
that some way of effectively translating
these beliefs because I think in some
ways we can think of it in the rivers of
rivers if the economy is doing well I
think peace is easier it is only when
economic conditions deteriorate and
people do it's not enough to go around
then all kinds of other ideas can be
used to you know point at enemies and
and then generally it is not a very
happy state of affairs well that that's
right and that's a very interesting
point you make which gets to some of the
very complicated issues regarding how
religion plays a role as part of
identity as opposed to a force unto
itself and can you speak to in the case
of Sri Lanka do you think that there is
some sort of inevitability about the
violent conflict because of the
mythology or the national belief about
the origin of the people and the right
of the Sinhala people that is special
above others in Sri Lanka does that
necessarily bring us to conflict I would
again go back to what I just said there
is I don't think I think the ideology
would have survived anyway but I think
the the reason why it has become the
basis of the conflict is precisely
because of lack of development in the
economy had the country prospered and
there were enough jobs and enough access
to education and opportunities I think
people would have
you know forgotten these they you good
nature all kinds of fantasies about your
own identity and still they can be quite
harmless and in fact I'm in some ways
talking through experience because I do
recall in my personal experience a
period of time in Sri Lankan history
that it was somewhat like that although
it was not there was never any kind of
overwhelming prosperity but but there
was a system of society just before the
just before and after the British
occupation the actually people do not in
I think adequately differentiate between
when we talk about imperialism
colonialism they don't adequately
distinguish between you know the various
stages of colonialism it is of course
but completely correct that during the
early years of British rule they
committed atrocities and and but then
towards the latter when you get to later
imperialism that colonialism
I think the liberal humane ideas that
were also growing in England had an
effect on the colonial government and
they introduced parliamentary
institutions the rule of law and noise
like human rights and various kinds of
modern ideas and not to mention modern
institutions so the country was actually
there was a kind of civility strain you
know it's a kind of civility that you
would suppose that would develop in
under be ideal Buddhist conditions so I
in fact feel that you know the the
Protestant Reformation brought about a
kind of a Buddhist spirit or as much as
I suppose you know whatever my tribe and
others would have meant by meant by what
they were arguing about so so I think in
the case of the Buddhist identity it
could have remained
perfectly you know integral to the
society without ever really becoming an
anti-social force that's a very
interesting perspective now on a similar
note let me ask you this then there are
different theories of history and there
are some that would argue that the
directions that history takes are very
much dependent on historical forces and
then there's another school of thought
that would argue that individual leaders
shape everything so could I ask for your
thoughts on why it is that in some
situations
perhaps in India with the the rise of
Mahatma Gandhi or in the United States
when Martin Luther King became an
important leader how do we understand
the forces that allow us to draw on the
most positive that our religions have to
offer as opposed to situations in which
more negative and destructive aspects of
the religion are drawn out do you have
some thoughts on that to share well
about the first part of your question it
is the individual or the larger movement
history in some ways I suppose it's it's
a little bit of both and in Sri Lanka
there is I think is a your question very
relevant to Sri Lanka in the sense that
there is a very powerful personality
his name is Dharmapala and it is
prefixed by the term an agaric and
gurkha means homeless and this man was
he so he called himself homeless because
he he didn't want to become a Buddhist
monk Buddhist monks are traditionally
describes as homeless meaning they have
given up their belongings and their
homes and family life and so on but he
didn't want to be Buddhist monk because
had he become a Buddhist monk he thought
he would not be able to to do the kinds
of things that he want to do for this
society therefore he remained a layman
but he became a very men celibate
so he called him his homeless Dharmapala
so but but the paradox about him is that
he was trained in Christian missionary
schools in the early period of British
rule
in the late 19th century and early 20th
century and and one of the one of the
problems of machinery Christianity in
probably all of the world but certainly
I know from sri lankan experience is the
the insensitivity of the machine race to
the local people and the colleges
because it is not the case that the
people didn't like Christianity it is
they didn't like the way it was you know
trust on them so this man when he was
young in Protestant Christian school the
Christian fathers were the priests or
teachers even humiliated by the kinds of
things they said about Sri Lanka and
Buddhism so obviously a gifted the child
he he had this thing inside him and when
he later on as a young man got to
understand more about his own culture
and Buddhism he became a radical
critique of Christianity and and in some
ways it also had had bad effect on him
in the sense that his creativity was
somewhat sort of channel in the
direction of bitterness and sense of
frustration and so on so he became very
xenophobic in a way and he entered he
who really gave a renewed kind of
validation to the ancient myth that I
just talked about you know that well ago
about the exclusivity of the ownership
of the island by the singular Buddhist
this notion and and the application of
the single Buddhist people to protect
position Buddhism and then make it the
most you know forceful thing in society
and this kind of this theory was given
an enormous boost by the work of
dharmapala
and that had I think that define the
particular turn
the Buddhist moment took in sri lanka
which unfortunately has had had severe
consequences and what do you think it
would take at this moment where we see
that events in sri lanka recently have
been so terribly negative what would it
take or what could be done to try in
this in this difficult situation to draw
out the reconciliation and peace that is
present in a different strand of
buddhism or is that possible
at this juncture well I think it is
possible and we need to approach it not
so much directly from a religious point
of view but it has to I think take much
broader kind of view and to begin with
the government's approach is a military
solution to the civil war I don't think
that is going to work I think it's very
important that the central grievances
that underlie the problem be addressed
which would be actually devolution of
power to the minorities it is now it is
part of the traditional political
Buddhist belief that this island this
country is one and so so any kind of
devolution of power is and the theme are
to them so I think therefore it is
important that the that either religious
leaders or political leaders exert some
influence on - so that you convey their
ideas about the country they need to
somehow accommodate minorities and come
up with a effective set of proposal for
devolution and that's one that's the
kind of larger political question but in
general there has been a different kind
of problem there has been a decline in
the social order in general the the
breakdown of law and order and
compromising of parliamentary
institutions human rights violations and
not to mention also complete disarray
and in the public ran off for example
the administrative structures and
there's been a general disintegration of
the social order I think for this to be
corrected it is very important that that
institutions of the society particularly
of the government like the major
divisions like the legislature the
judiciary and the executive these should
have their independence and they should
each in other words the the
politicization of everything that we see
today needs to be corrected and already
there is legislation for it is called
the 17th amendment it's in the
Constitution as it is for example the
supposing some kind of crime is
committed and and the police start
investigations then a politician will
intervene and say don't do this because
this is my friend and that's a very
simplistic simplified example but this
kind of thing happening all the time in
others government it has politicized
everything so the 17th amendment is an
attempt to to depoliticize to give
independence to the to the to the media
to the police the judiciary the
administrative system for example the
senior public servants love the sinner
Administrative Service I cannot make
administrative decisions because the
politicians interfere and so this has
been
really destructive of the public
interest so I think parallel to the
search for a peace through devolution
there should also be mechanisms in the
broader social order in particular -
there should be an attempt to put into
effect the 17th amendment in fact the
fact that the amendment has been there
but has not been put into effect is also
illustrative of Sri Lanka's problem that
there is good there are good intentions
but they are not followed through and so
we'll have to think of some way of you
know you know affecting that
follow-through and one possibility is
that religious leaders might be able to
you know exert some pressure and it
should be understood not so much as some
kind of sectarian thing there should be
some unity some kind of I think
communication not only within the
Buddhist different within the different
Buddhist divisions but also among
religions I think if the religious
leadership of all the major religions
and there are four major religions
representing Salonga Buddhism
Christianity Hinduism and Islam if all
these people can get together and exert
an infinite need not be confined to them
there is also interestingly enough civil
society in sri lanka which is very quite
admirable I mean dependently and through
against all gods had been expressing
their waves and coming up with extremely
you know civilized ideas about society
and so if they are can if you can
imagine some sort of civil society
movement of both the clergy of all the
religions and these intellectuals and
other people who were committed to
certain kind of social values I think
something can be done and do you see
local Buddhist leaders who you believe
will take up that call unfortunately the
Buddhist leadership itself is very
partisan and they are themselves not
they have not shown them themselves we
capable of objectively understand the
this paradigm of the myth of political
Buddhism and and its historical nature
and its relation to the economy that
kind of thing they have not been able to
understand and therefore the Buddhist
leadership itself has been rather
disappointing but that is not to say
there are no individual members in that
leadership there are some I think those
people will have to talk to other people
are the leaders of religions plus I
think civil society leaders in the in
the secular society and do you believe
there's a role you noted earlier in our
discussion that the Dalai Lama has taken
a position in his interpretation of
Buddhism that is different than the
prevailing Buddhist theology in Sri
Lanka do you think that other leaders
like the Dalai Lama from other parts of
the Buddhist world could play a role in
Sri Lanka
well conceivably but I think it is
probably better if the initiator comes
from within the country because there it
it is there is a lot of popular you know
xenophobia and there is a distrust
mistrust of foreigners and and so I
think in fact the case of Dalai Lama is
a very interesting case because I have
participated in discussions like this in
different parts of this country in
Washington DC and other places and the
question has come up over and over again
why Cannot Srilanka invited that ILOM
know that's a very big problem because
the dalai lama represent what we call
the mahayana buddhism and sri lanka is
is that there about the Buddhist country
this is these are two major divisions in
Buddhism and the sri lankan buddhist
hierarchy would be very opposed to the
idea of the Lama making any you know
being invited to anything and therefore
he will not although the Lama is
enormous
prestige in the West he does not come on
same kind of prestige in sri lanka i see
then returning to the question of a
resolution drawing on the positive
forces of religion from within Sri Lanka
how would you how would you describe the
obligations that a committed Buddhist in
sri lanka who disagrees with this
prevailing radical and violent
interpretation of buddhist
responsibilities how should such a
person see their responsibilities in sri
lanka
I think they should support the civil
society efforts to to bring about not
only narrowly conceived solution to the
present civil war but the general
problem I think the there's a general
malaise and that is really the problem
might even civil war is a manifestation
or an expression of this general problem
and and the way to address it as I said
is the putting into effect the 7th 17th
amendment to the Constitution and I
think the community leaders that you
have in mind could if they can somehow
communicate with each other then inform
themselves into some effective force and
then join hands with these religious
leaders and others civil society leaders
that is the way an individual I think
could help I see and and I ask on that
note it seems that throughout our
discussion we're returning to the theme
that what is really needed to establish
peace in Sri Lanka his work on the the
government and the public policy side
from a number of aspects with religion
as part of that part of the background
perhaps but what we seem to be saying is
that it's not a religious dialogue as
such that will actually help to overcome
this conflict is that fair to summarize
yes I think I think that would be
because it is not to begin with anything
to do with religious ideas per se it is
nothing to do with spiritual and moral
system at all it is it is much more to
do with the politicization political
Buddhism and for example in the lima
once I count the king before going to
war says this I'm not going to this is
not a fight for my glory this is this is
for I'm fighting for Buddhism and this
should sound rather familiar to you in
this election season with but the king
is saying religion first me second you
know that's right that's right
absolutely and what what lessons do you
think if any this approach that we're
talking about to resolve the situation
Sri Lanka what what lessons does that
provide for other conflicts in which
religion plays a role or would you
rather argue that each one should be
looked at separately oh definitely each
one should be looked at separately but I
would suspect from general sociological
point of view that that it needs to be
addressed in a kind of a total istic way
I would also suspect just like in Sri
Lanka there are forces outside the
sphere of religion itself and that are
very crucial in the in the in the in the
creation in the etiology of these
conflicts and they should be addressed
I say well thank you very much for your
thoughts and thank you for coming to
speak with the students in faith and
globalization today thank you very much
nice to be here